foreign
[Music]
ERS for the Wall Street Journal this is
a special episode of tech news briefing
part of our four-part series on climate
Tech it's no secret the production of
food especially meat releases a lot of
carbon into the atmosphere
in fact more than a third of global
greenhouse gas emissions caused by human
activity are directly related to our
food supply chain according to the
United Nations
lab-grown meat or cultivated meat could
reduce that by growing the animal cells
without growing the whole animal but
it's an expensive Endeavor compared to
making meat Alternatives from plants and
those carbon reduction benefits only
really materialize if the industry makes
certain choices about production and if
it reaches a scale that lets it make
products at a cost that's on par with
traditional meat for this installment of
our climate in Tech series how do the
low-carbon claims of lab-grown meat
stack up against all the Alternatives
and what will the young industry need to
do to get out of the lab and onto our
dinner plates
[Music]
to find out why more startups are
looking to produce this kind of protein
and the challenges they'll face I'm
joined by Elliot Schwartz he researches
the ins and outs of cultivated meat for
good food Institute a think tank that
supports plant and cell-based
alternatives to animal protein hi Elliot
thanks for joining me it's great to be
here thanks so much for having me okay
so let's talk a little bit about what
the landscape for this cultured or
cultivated meat looks like I mean can
you give me a sense of sort of what
companies are out there and what stages
of development they're in so overall the
industry is still pretty nascent the
technology was really introduced to the
public back in 2013 when the first
Burger was tasted on on live TV in in
London and the first companies formed a
few years after that in 2015. as of
today there's around 150 companies
around the world that are focused on
developing either cultivated meat
products for consumers or technologies
that feed directly into the industry it
sounds like what you're describing is
still a pretty new industry so how big
is it and how fast do you expect it to
grow so there's been about
2.6 billion dollars raised across all
the companies in the industry since
really the first Inception of the first
companies in terms of growth so right
now really companies are at what we call
the pilot scale of production which
means they're really developing the sort
of formative technology and processes
that will enable them to scale up at
larger production sizes where those
products can actually reach a broader
set of consumers so let's talk a little
bit more about that environmental impact
what kind of climate impact do we expect
cultured meat you know lab grown meat to
have compared to what we might think of
as regular meat you know the kind we get
from slaughtering animals so cultivated
Meats essentially is a technology that
enables you to have a more efficient
mode of meat production essentially that
means that fewer feed inputs are needed
to get the same amount of calories or
protein out of the product and the way
that scientists use to assess the
environmental impact of really any
product or technology is something
called a life cycle assessment that
looks at the environmental impact of all
of those things Upstream in the supply
chain so in this case the feed that the
cells consume or the feed that the
animals consume as well as the
environmental impact of the production
itself at the facility and there's been
several of these studies performed for
cultivated meat technology and the good
thing is that they're all fairly aligned
in their conclusions and those
conclusions essentially state that land
use will be significantly decreased
compared to Conventional forms of animal
meat production so anywhere between 60
to up to 95 percent decrease in the
amount of land that is necessary to
create the meat product
and if you look at Carbon emissions this
could be anywhere between 17 to 90
percent reduction in carbon emissions
but this is important to understand that
in order to get these large reductions
or comparatively large reductions in
carbon emissions the cultivated meat
should be produced with renewable energy
technology essentially this technology
is replacing the animal body with a sort
of a bioreactor vessel that needs to be
warmed externally so that you're
inputting energy that way into the
process and so generally the energy use
for cultivated meat technology is higher
but the flip side of that is it can be
supplied with renewable forms of energy
and thus lowering the carbon footprint
overall
I mean so that sounds like it has the
potential then to lower the carbon
footprint but it could also have this
potentially expansive carbon footprint
if say they're not using renewable
energy to power the process of making
this cultivated meat is that right yeah
so of course it depends on what animal
you're comparing to so the footprint of
beef and lamb production for instance is
just so high that cultivated meat even
if you are producing it with a
conventional Energy Mix with
predominantly fossil fuels it would
still have a lower carbon footprint than
that form of meat production I think the
way that people can relate to this is
similar to electric vehicles where today
the electricity that powers your vehicle
you might be plugging into a grid that
has a high percent of Renewables or it
could be a higher percent of fossil
fuels but obviously the Technologies
Renewable Energy Technologies are being
installed throughout the world and so
the grid and energy systems in general
should be cleaner as time moves forward
and this really coincides nicely with
the timeline of cultivated meat
development which we expect not to
really occur overnight but to me more
scaling up in later stages of this
decade and into the 2030s when the
energy systems are already becoming
cleaner
cultivated meat compared to
environmental impact
so there have been studies as well on
some of these plant-based products from
companies like impossible foods and
beyond meat generally speaking
plant-based products have a lower impact
because you're really taking it directly
from the plant Source processing those
plant ingredients and then those go
directly into the product whereas with
cultivated meat you have to take you
know say plant ingredients break them
down and then feed them to cells where
there's some sort of let's say energy
loss in that process now with that said
cultivated meat produced using renewable
energy technology would have a footprint
that's similar to let's say an
impossible Burger today which is still
lower than conventional chicken
production really any form of meat
production as well and of course seeing
with those plant-based products if those
are produced as well with renewable
energy then the footprint can be even
lower Elliot Schwartz lead scientist for
cultivated meat at good food Institute
thank you so much for joining us thanks
so much for having me
cultivated meat companies promise big
reductions in carbon emissions over
other kinds of meat
but people following the sector say to
get those benefits they're going to need
to do a few things including relying on
renewable energy producing their meat in
bulk and of course convincing Shoppers
to buy it
Berkeley california-based upside Foods
is giving that a go
after being valued at over 1 billion
dollars by investors last spring in
November it cleared a major regulatory
hurdle with the Food and Drug
Administration for its lab-grown poultry
the FDA says its chicken is safe to eat
Based on data provided by upside foods
that takes upside one step closer to
supermarket shelves though it still
needs sign off from the Department of
Agriculture
but upside hasn't actually sold anything
yet and the market for meat Alternatives
is growing more crowded even as
consumers are pulling back from buying
them on top of that if part of the goal
is to reduce the carbon footprint of
meat production why start with chicken
which as we've heard has a smaller
carbon impact than beef or lamb with me
to discuss how the company plans to
address all of that is upside Foods
Chief Operating Officer Amy Chen hi Amy
thank you for coming on Tech news
briefing hi Zoe it's great to be with
you today what does it mean to be
cultivated meat how do you make it so
you essentially take cells from an
animal so it could be from a fertilized
egg or from an adult animal or Junior
animal you then select the cells that
are the best for tastes that are going
to be delicious and that also grow
really well you feed them a blend of
nutrients and things like amino acids
and salts and sugars that cells would
normally get inside of their body but in
this case they're getting them in a
stainless steel cultivator or a
cultivator that resembles what you might
see in a beer brewery so you put those
cells in there you feed them they're
happy when they are being fed so they
grow they double and after anywhere from
7 to 14 days you can harvest the meat
cells and formulate it into any product
that you want can you tell me a little
bit more about the tech that it's used
to make this I mean how new is this
technology the technology at some level
has never been used to make meat but
very similar things have been used for
hundreds if not thousands of years for
things like beer brewing or even a
sourdough starter that you might have
for bread or yogurt Factory it's similar
principles in terms of how cells are fed
and then ultimately grow what is the
expense here of upside chicken versus
traditional chicken in the near term the
price is still going to be higher we are
not at the full level of scale that we
would need to be to optimize and to
really capture those efficiencies so
when we first launched I would expect us
to be at a premium price to things like
organic or free range but over the next
10 to 15 years the goal is absolutely
price parity and as you continue to see
some of the supply chain challenges the
avian flu or swine flu issues the price
of conventional meat is continuing to go
up our prices will go in the opposite
direction and kind of in that time frame
that I named I think they'll cross okay
from that I want to Pivot a little bit
to funding in April upside Foods raised
400 million dollars in its series C
round given the economic conditions how
are you approaching future funding
rounds considering that you'll need to
reach scalability to get more people to
know who you are and to get to that
price parity I think we have enough from
that last raise to build out the proof
of concept and the commercial scale
demonstration that this technology works
it also allows us to do a significant
amount of consumer education so between
those two things we're excited that we
will build a very strong foundation for
the next chapter which will ultimately
be more about scaling and replicating
the work that we will do in our
commercial plant what about competition
because there are a lot more you know
meat substitutes and you know
alternative meat products that are in
the grocery store and at the same time
we're seeing slumping sales of those
kinds of products so when you can get
into stores how do you deal with that
sort of two-pronged hit more competition
vision and lower demand for this kind of
product I would actually characterize
what we're seeing not as lower demand
for alternative products in general I
would say it's a very sobering reminder
from consumers that their expectations
for products like Meek are incredibly
high and if I think there's a challenge
in the current plant-based slump that
we're seeing it's ultimately that that
product from a price and versatility and
product performance perspective doesn't
fit into people's diets the way that
meat does and part of what attracted me
and I think part of the bigger vision of
cultivated meat is that it's not a
alternative that is plant-based or vegan
or vegetarian it is meat that's made
from real animal cells which at some
level is complicated from a technology
perspective but from a product
translation perspective and consumer
experience is a much more direct line do
you see a connection between lab-grown
chicken and beef because beef has a
bigger impact on the climate than
chicken the way that we're thinking
about it is a couple fold first off as
we talked about earlier the overall
process for making meat whether it's
chicken or beef is very similar we've
chosen chicken just because it is the
most consumed before we move on to more
complex and different kinds of meats
like beef or others Amy Chen CEO of
upside Foods thanks so much for joining
us it's been a pleasure Zoe I appreciate
it
alright that's it for this episode of
tech news briefing be sure to check out
the other episodes of our special series
on new climate Tech and for more Tech
news head over to our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]